this is a storyboard before parasite was
shot director bongjun ho turned his
written script into a series of drawn
images that are then used to guide and
Inspire the movie's visuals not every
director and every film uses storyboards
but pretty much every film follows this
approach text and supplementary visual
material are used to guide the
production and it's only in production
and afterwards in post-production that
sound design is brought in as a creative
element in the film making process it's
the tradition for sound to follow not to
lead is how Oscar winning sound designer
Randy Tom described this status quo he
says that's strange because we also know
that sounds are evocative sounds suggest
images at least as much as images
suggest sound so what if we flipped this
status quo on its
head what you're hearing now is the
Sonic storyboard for the 2019 film The
souvenir this storyboard was created for
director Joanna hog by by sound designer
Jonathan web as we listen we hear a
montage of sounds that establish a sense
of place atmosphere and mood we hear
television and radio programs as well as
music and the sound of a table being set
evoking domestic warmth and a sense of
nostalgia and almost innocence but if we
listen to this roughly 45-minute audio
piece in real time what we experience
through this collection of sounds is a
descent from that nostalgic innocent
into an atmosphere of tension and
confusion which captures the emotional
Arc of the
[Music]
story I've always loved the process of
film making just as much as movies
themselves and I'm especially interested
in filmmakers who approach this process
in new and inventive ways this concept
of bringing in sound design earlier in
the pre-production process could be used
and applied to many different movies in
a variety of ways several filmmakers and
sound designers have explored and
advocated for this idea over the years
most recently I know of this kind of
thing being done for Denny Ville moves
Dune I'll get more into those other
possibilities later but first I want to
detail how Jonathan and Joanna explored
a Fresh Approach to film making during
the making of what just so happens to be
one of my favorite movies of the last
decade do you want to go from the
souvenir is a beautiful film which I
won't spoil here but I want to give you
enough of a overview so that you have
the context to appreciate what went into
making it part one follows Julie a young
woman living in the'80s as she navigates
film school and a troubling relationship
with a mysterious older man
Anthony part two shows her processing
this relationship as she makes a film
about it you can really tell that they
had chemistry much of the beauty of the
film to me is how it unfolds very gently
from Julie's limited perspective nothing
is laid out explicitly for the audience
there's a kind of impressionistic
quality to the way the plot unfolds that
I love for example most movies that
Center on a relationship don't depict
the meaning of the two characters in the
relationship like
this in A Moment Like This the director
is usually signaling somehow to the
audience that this moment is significant
that these two characters meeting is
going to play a significant role in the
story instead we get he an incredible
naturalism that kind of mirrors how we
experience these things in real life um
which I found really really interesting
this example also shows how Joanna is
prioritizing sound in her storytelling
we hear Anthony's voice before we see
his face um so that's why we thought
this would work out the same is true of
Julie the main character yes it's a
about a 16-year-old boy called Tony the
character of Julie is Loosely based on
writer and director Joanna hog herself
self and the relationship that Julie has
in part one is Loosely based on a real
relationship from Joanna's life and then
in part two we see Julie adapting her
real life into a film there's a
directness to this where it almost feels
like we're watching Joanna process what
it's like to make this film as she makes
the film through the character of Julie
it's a great exploration of the process
of creating art relationships and loss
of Innocence that feels deeply grounded
naturalistic and personal throughout so
I wasn't surprised to learn that the
process of creating it involves some
unique approaches to film making when
Jonathan and Joanna first spoke he had
already made a few experimental
soundscape mood board pieces for novels
that he had read there's a kind of
cinematic landscape that's playing out
as you're reading and could I do
something
that kept you in that kind of moment um
through sound Joanna had heard these
pieces and thought it might be helpful
to have Jonathan create something
similar for an autobiographical short
story she had written which she was
planning on turning into a film you know
a sort of collage of sounds that I'm
thinking of around the film itself and
sort of in a way becomes a storyboard in
sound in a sense she she writes this
what's like a kind of mini Nolla and she
sent me the story and just said look you
know just do what you like here's this
thing now make something that sounds
like it for Joanna and Jonathan the goal
here wasn't necessarily to create
something that would be a guide for the
film's final sound design in the same
way a visual storyboard is a guide
specifically for the cinematography you
know not that one's then pursuing those
exact sounds in the finished film
because I think there's always a danger
it's so easy to get attached to
something it's more about um trying to
encourage visuals as well as sound in
the mind of the director sort of
stimulating his or her imagination with
sound well Jonathan ended up creating
were essentially these two roughly
45-minute audio montages that created an
immersive soundscape for the
stories the story is About a Boy age 16
he's in his last term of a comprehensive
School in sundland and obviously about
to CL a prospect of finding a
job it's it's essentially a part of film
reproduction research as a story kind of
progresses from page to screen you're
providing the director with a different
perspective a new angle to look at the
story through sound offering them
details about the fictional space uh
characterization the kind of
Environmental and Cultural conditions
that are you know at play Within the
narrative from you know essentially a
Sonic perspective for me I assemble a
range of audio materials music field
recordings archival recordings sound
effects uh and I bring all those
together to make uh an audio
interpretation of the full story it's a
translation of a story on its way to
becoming a film and what's incredible to
me listening to what Jonathan created is
that while you don't pick up on many of
the explicit details of the plot and the
characters you do get a really strong
sense of where they are and the tone and
mood of the story and you even feel the
emotional Arc of the story for the
characters as the story board progresses
that you are a
traitor of
Jer Jonathan is crafting something that
specifically feels cinematic as well
drawing inspiration from evocative
subjective uses of sound in films like
Todd Haynes Carol and even Joanna Hog's
pre previous work like
exhibition another thing that makes this
project unique is some of the material
that Jonathan had available to pull from
and luckily for me she carried around
with her a tape recorder between 1980
and 1985 um so she had this massive
personal Archive of recordings and so
she had tapes with just you know just
just her leaving a recorder on by
accident in a room in her apartment and
walking out and just this the perfect
room tone from 1980 so when we hear a
recording of Joanna having a
conversation with a parasitologist in
the storyboard and I think the ideas are
there and they can be brought to
fruition my suggestion is this those are
actual recorded conversations from that
time in Joanna's life and these get
adapted into the scenes where Julie sees
a parasyche in part two that he didn't
know how to go forward with life in this
deception that had become his life I
would wager that you two had more
disagreements than you had had for the
period of time a little Easter egg
unrelated to the sound is that the woman
who plays the parisy here is the same
woman Joanna actually saw in her real
life 30 years prior and Jonathan was
invited onto the set of the production
of part one where he recorded audio that
made it into the Sonic storyboard for
part
two have some lights please which then
went on to influence the production of
part two which depicts a sort of
fictionalized version of the production
of part one this blurring of reality and
fiction in the Sonic storyboards I think
is more than just a neat piece of trivia
about the behind the scenes of the film
it feels intimately tied to what the
story is about the material is real
those people
exist but I am designing new
ones to fit what I want to make Julie in
the film is blurring reality and fiction
in the stories that she's telling on
screen which is what Joanna is doing in
the story that she's telling on screen
for example when Julie looks at photos
that she's taken in the movie we're
looking at photos that are from Joanna's
own personal
archive to me this is most clearly
represented when Julie watches her own
movie in part two when Julie watches the
souvenir she doesn't see the movie that
she's been making throughout the film
the actors that we've seen her filming
are replaced with herself and the
character of Anthony it's like she
enters this bizarre surreal space where
she can no longer separate her own art
from her own memory so I don't think
it's a coincidence that the Sonic
storyboards that Jonathan made are
literally delete that sometimes we're
hearing actual recordings from Joanna's
past recordings from the production of
part one Jonathan's surreal sound design
and archival clips from other movies all
being mixed together I told you what
this show means to me well this is what
it does mean hello hello Murphy that's
the process of creating art that's what
happening when we create something we
end up mixing all these different
influences together and pushing out
something new whether we are conscious
of it or not but again the goal here
wasn't to create something for public
consumption and so while Jonathan's work
is a piece of art in its own right I'm
interested in how this work fit into the
larger process of creating the souvenir
you know when something's so close to
you and that you've experience it's very
hard to see it or yeah it's a different
understanding of it so it's just just
turning it into another form so it can
be just seen from another angle I know
for myself personally sound engages part
of my imagination that looking at
visuals doesn't you were helping to
encapsulate some of the mood of of the
story of the real story which then
inspired the fictional story there's
something about hearing but not seeing
that I think provokes you to try to
imagine visuals that fit with the sounds
you can imagine for Joanna as she's is
going through the process of expanding
this story for the screen that being
able to listen to a specific soundscape
that evokes the time place and personal
history that the story is about would be
provocative and inspiring it's not that
sound is better than visuals for these
purposes but it does offer something
that visuals don't it's quite ambiguous
sound at times you know you participate
in the engagement between you know the
way the sounds projected at you and how
you you receive it the souvenir is about
this you know what's real what's
actually fiction you know and and sounds
sort of fit beautifully in that in that
space when I sort of combined Joanna's
authentic untreated recordings from that
period in her life with Rec my
reconstructions of you know what London
hubub was you know London Underground or
something was like in that in that
period when you layer the two over each
other even Joanna was sort of unsure
about what did she actually experience
in that in those moments and I think you
know that says a lot about sound's
ability to conjure experiences in a way
that maybe visuals don't even though the
explicit goal of the Sonic storyboards
wasn't to influence the sound of the
final film there are definitely some
similarities between the two
particularly in how Julie student film
was portrayed and in the treatment of
the film's reoccurring sound Motif it
seems to me like Jonathan's work had at
least some minor influence on how Joanna
hog and the supervising sound editor
yovon ader approached the film's sound
design and some of Jonathan's musical
selections even ended up in the final
film I think it's impossible from my
perspective to untangle how much of an
influence Jonathan's storyboards really
had on the final film obviously we can't
know what the movie would have looked
like had he not been involved but it
sounds like it offered Joanna a valuable
perspective based on what she says what
excited me is that it would be it would
just be part of the process of discovery
I like the fact that it felt like a new
form so it seems like the Sonic
storyboard process was valuable for this
project the themes it was exploring and
how Joanna wanted to work but would this
way of working of involving sound design
much earlier in the process apply to
other films sound design usually is
something that happens after the edit is
done the visual effects are done often
the score is even done and we don't have
any input into how all of that happened
Den need does this a very different way
Denny vnu is another director who has
been experimenting with this a little
bit earlier this year I spoke with Mark
Mangini Oscar winning sound designer
who's worked on Dune and Blade Runner
2049 and he talked about how Deni had
them do sound design for the worm before
certain visual effects were made
tradition has been you conceptualize a
shot the worm's going to reach the
desert here and it's going to travel
over here and then it's going to go dig
back into the sand there and we'll wait
6 months for that shot and we don't do
any work on that until we finally see
some mockup of the worm do this action
well Deni and Joe recognized that
sometimes the sound itself if we build
it before the shot is realized can
inform the way the graphic artists
actually animate what we're going to see
on screen and we did that a great deal
in Dune and this approach of not using
sound as a source of inspiration but
actually letting the sound lead the
charge is the approach that Randy Tom
has been advocating for for decades many
directors and writers even already use
sound in the form of music to guide the
creative process I know many directors
and writers myself included who write to
music and I know a lot of screenwriters
who will put together a playlist of
music to go with a screenplay not with
the intention of that music making it
into the final film but just sort of as
a soundtrack and Atmospheric extension
of the screenplay itself so what if
instead of limiting that to music you
designed soundscapes throughout the
pre-production and development process
of a film what if when a writer was
stuck on a script or when the script was
finished but before the concept art was
made a sound designer was brought on to
begin working on soundscapes for the
film The soundscapes or sonic
storyboards could influence rewrites
influence how the visuals of the film
are crafted and I can even imagine some
actors finding this helpful in
discovering and immersing themselves
into a character all this sounds great
but there are certainly barriers to
working this way sound is often one of
the last considerations on a film in
many ways is if you want to do this
you're battling against an industry that
already Cuts Corners even when it comes
to dialogue recording during production
I heard Randy say or maybe he wrote
Somewhere that one of the barriers to
this way of working is the industrial
imperative of the movies yeah and I
think that is the that's you know that's
the problem but both of us were unsure
about what the potential for this was
and even if it would work but that is
what being a filmmaker or an artist is
what I love so much about this
innovation in film making is that it
isn't the result of some technological
innovation Jonathan and Joanna didn't
decide to do this because some new
technology made it easier to do this
they pushed forward an approach that's
been barely explored simply because they
were willing to try something that
wasn't the status quo Joanna was willing
to pitch it to Jonathan and give it a
shot just for the sake of trying it not
knowing if it was going to work and this
is what's required to continue evolving
an art form sometimes it's easy to feel
like film making and movies have gotten
a little stale but I think this comes
from audiences and filmmakers putting
what a movie looks like and how it's
made inside a box but that box is often
defined more by just how it's always
been done than it is by what's actually
best or most artistically compelling
when it comes to film making or any
creative work we often have much much
more freedom in how we approach the work
than we really give ourselves but we
constrain ourselves unnecessarily
because exercising that creative freedom
involves taking risks risk is at odds
with the profit motive but that risk is
where any potential artistic Innovation
lies it's the holidays coming up which
means a lot of people are traveling and
I recently learned that if you're
booking your travel from within the
United States you're often charged more
than if you're booking from other
locations nordvpn the sponsor for this
video is one way that you can get around
this and save some money they did
research and discovered that by booking
hotels and car rentals outside the
United States you can sometimes save a
pretty significant amount of money a VPN
or a virtual private Network allows you
to change the location of where you're
browsing from so if you're in the United
States you can set your VPN to Mexico
and it looks like you're located in
Mexico to any of the websites that
you're visiting this comes in useful if
you want to save money on travel it also
comes in useful if you're traveling and
you want access to the same streaming
content that you normally watch if
you've ever been hit with that this
content is not available in your region
message you know it can be incredibly
frustrating nordvpn is the solution to
that changing your location to get
access to content or save money isn't
the only thing that vpn's are good for
they also help protect your privacy by
shielding your web traffic from your
internet service provider and nordvpn
comes with a bunch of other tools that
help protect you from malware and other
threats to your Internet Security a VPN
is one of those basic internet tools
that I think every internet user should
have at their disposal and nordvpn makes
an incredibly easy to use fast VPN that
you can use on all your devices when you
go to nordvpn.com
tflight clicking my link in the
description you'll get four bonus months
for free when you sign up for the 2-year
plan nordvpn is incredibly affordable
easy to use it's going to give you
access to the content that you love save
you money when you're booking on travel
and help protect you as you're browsing
the web go to
nordvpn.com
tflight to sign up for that 2-year plan
and you'll get those bonus 4 months for
free for using my code click the link in
the description below or on the screen
thanks again to nordvpn for sponsoring
this
[Music]
video